that was that it was like nothing I've
ever seen it went so quickly from a tiny
fire on the outside and fizzed up down
sideways looked like someone that poured
petrol down the side of the building
71 people died in the Grenfell fire this
firefighter tells us more lives could
have been saved a making residents stay
inside and wait for help was a mistake
when we were sent into the tower we
couldn't see much going on to the
stairwell on certain floors it was
eerily quiet and he soon became apparent
that the radios weren't working and we
had lost all communication the higher up
we went in the tower I felt like you
were very much alone
you couldn't radio back to let people
know where you were what you were doing
if you had done the job you had been
sent up there to do do you think that
more life could have been saved I think
there would have been more chance of
getting people out yeah if we'd had
proper radio communications yeah there
was a chance we could have got a few
more people out knowing how advanced
communications and the communication
systems that we've got out there the
fact that we are not given the best
equipment to save people's lives that
does make me angry
Sky News has learned that there was
serious doubt about the quality of the
radio communication system the fire
brigade union had argued there were
issues with it for some time well before
the night of the fire but perhaps more
controversial was telling residents to
stay in their flats and wait for help a
policy this firefighter believes should
have been changed looking back I do
think there was a stage in that night
that the stay-put policy should have
been changed I don't think it was done
early enough I don't know if it would
have caused some kind of stampede on the
stairwell I don't know if it would have
saved more lives or killed more people I
really don't know but I just believe
from what I saw on the outside of that
building it was quite apparent quite
early on that these people should have
been given a chance to get out so yeah
once it was seen that we had lost
control of that fire the stay-put policy
should have been changed the tower had
23 floors coroner reports show many
bodies were found in flats on the upper
levels as people fled to escape the fire
but the equipment firefighters had made
reaching the top practically impossible
we carry standard duration breathing
apparatus which gives about 25 to 30
minutes of air depending on how hard you
were working inside the building so you
can imagine sending someone up that
stairwell up to the 20th 21st 22nd 23rd
floor by the time they get up there they
haven't got hardly any time at all
before they've got to come back down
again he soon became apparent during the
night that sending us in with standard
rather than extended durations was
literally suicide we were going in there
doing two minutes of work and then we
had to run out again
a few firefighters whose air ran out who
came down with what they would say
sucking on plastic it's a miracle no
firefighters were killed during that
night it was quite clear early on our
standard duration breathing apparatus
wasn't good enough and that's not all
this firefighter questions the policy of
not having longer length ladders for
high-rise fires someone in their wisdom
decided that long ladders weren't needed
at these high-rise incidents the fire
brigade have said that those ladders
wouldn't have made a difference that
night but they've also decided to bring
them back so let us go to initial
attendance and high rises from now on
and so read into that what you will do
you think it would have made difference
in the night a ladder carries a monitor
which can put a hell of a lot more water
on the fire than what we can with just
the hose I don't know but there's a
chance it could have controlled it there
is a chance if it was there right from
the start him I've kept it to the lower
floors it would have been above the
floor of the fire so it would have been
raining down water on to the fire it was
such a quick severe rapid spread we're
never going to know if it would have
made a difference but it definitely
wouldn't have made matters worse
of all the firefighters on duty some
were highly experienced others just
weeks into the job for all of them the
events of that night was something
they'd never experienced
when your whole communication system
breaks down it turns everything into
guesswork it was the biggest failure of
the night as far as the fire brigade was
concerned
no one could talk to anyone outside you
imagine a firefighter going up to a
certain floor in Grenfell tower and
telling someone to stay put because
that's what they've been told to tell
them and not knowing that the outside of
the building is fully engulfed in flames
now firefighters have to live with that
because no one could tell them inside
the building that there is a raging
inferno outside I'm sure I know
firefighters would have made a decision
to get more people out of that building
if they knew what was going on on the
outside of that building
the tower was literally crumbling apart
I can only describe it as like a war
zone out there in a certain stages we
were taking casualties out and taking as
many firefighters with breathing
apparatus into the building and you
literally fell into craters and things
are exploding above your head and we
were using riot shields to protect
people going in and out of the building
nothing can prepare you for what
happened that night
this fire presented challenges like no
other and then the realization the
cladding on the outside of the building
was not only flammable but it was
waterproof the water was literally
bouncing off the cladding we were trying
get angles to try and get inside it at
certain stages I can't explain it
the water was hitting the fire and
seemed to be pushing it out somewhere
else we couldn't stop it we'd never seen
anything like it we've never had any
sort of training for this sort of stuff
and the fact that this cladding is on so
many buildings around this country
surely firefighters should know about it
and surely if it is allowed on some sort
of training should be given to us to at
least prepare us for this sort of fire
this is the headquarters of the London
Fire Brigade they've refused to discuss
the points we've raised on camera
instead sending a statement from the
Deputy Assistant Commissioner Andy Bell
in it he says it's essential that we
understand what happened on the night of
the Grenfell tower fire to prevent such
an incident ever happening again
firefighters will give evidence properly
later this year as part of the public
inquiry and every aspect of the brigade
response is part of the ongoing police
investigation
we cannot undermine the legal processes
and reacts to unofficial claims at this
time firefighters on the front line that
night say the memories will haunt them
forever just looking up at the tower and
sitting there after being in that
building and trying to recover and
looking at all the shocked faces of all
the firefighters it was horrible
it's like a numbness and just wide-eyed
firefighters who are just in shock
I've been in two fires in tower block
since and I'm not gonna lie it is always
at the back of my mind and it will be at
the back of my mind for the rest of my
career and I might make different
decisions than I would have before 14th
of June this probably changed me as a
firefighter but when it comes to it you
just have to do your job and carry on
I'm a completely changed man I live with
it day to day and there's not a day goes
past that I don't think about it and
it's really tough there's still so much
guilt as well that we had to leave 71
people in there
you